thousands of flights been grounded today
all through the weekend as well it's
been a major challenge for folks to get
home from christmas from the weekend all
across the country the reasons well bad
weather in some parts of the country and
also the relentless pandemic bianca
holmen live this afternoon at reed
international airport with the impact
there bianca good afternoon
a disappointing end to a holiday weekend
take a look at the boards up here
here at reid international more than a
dozen arrivals and departures were
canceled from a variety of carriers on
monday stuck at your destination
hundreds of flights were canceled across
the country there were another 6 000
delayed these cancellations are during
the busiest time of year for travel tsa
screened just over 2 million travelers
on thursday december 23rd airlines like
alaska airlines blame weather in the
pacific northwest and united airlines
blame
united airlines blames staffing issues
for changes i spoke with travelers
edward and suzette spears from texas
they tell me they planned for the worst
their inbound flight was delayed and
they were concerned about their morning
departure being canceled
we got a bag of snacks
just in case we had a bag of snacks and
honestly we stayed at an airbnb oh yeah
great airbnb i told my kids you know
let's go ahead on and wash since we can
so if we have to stay you know the
clothes are clean so yeah we were
prepared for the just in case
so these cancellations also impacted
stocks of u.s airlines and other travel
related companies shares of american
airlines group united airlines delta and
southwest were down between 0.2 percent
and 0.8 percent on monday now airport
officials tell us they are well staffed
for their information booths to help
answer questions about those
cancellations and also they strongly
recommend checking in with your carrier
before you get to the airport bianca
holmen live local now